georgette à nice est une grande grande
joueuse de bridge oui oui et une raison
à ça fait une grosse connerie la
tribune raison parce que c'est un
génèrent les yeux qu'est ce que vous
voulez c'est pas moi vous vous demandez
un contre un par exemple vous le
réussissez
alors vous êtes fier un bout du taillage
de gagner le tournoi
me regarde ça m'arrive heureusement
alors vous ouvrez la feuille de la table
précédente et vous vous apercevez
qu'elle aussi a demandé le même contrat
et qu'elle l'a réussi mais que par
contre elle elle a fait un tout petit
puis de plus alors adieu veau vache
cochon couvée le contrat le tournoi
foutu alors on prend là 2e donne parce
qu'ils ne continuent au ghana de
l'espoir ont réussi le contrat
on est fiers on rouvre la donne
précédente et on s'aperçoit que la table
davant avait réussi le contrôle avait
également demandé mais que cette fois
cette fois c'est nous qui avons fait la
petite levée supplémentaire parce que
vous aviez mieux jouer oui alors on
jette un regard faussement modeste sur
les adversaires en disant oh nous avons
eu de la chance
dans le but de nous mêmes on est
convaincu qu'on a merveilleusement bien
c'est arrivé c'est ça le bris ben le
bruit du rallye pour modeste tous
contents comment vous est venue cette
passion pour le bridge en particulier
mais pour les cartes en général
bien coûter c'est parce que j'aime bien
comptés et qu'il ya dans le bridge il ya
presque acté que dans la bonnotte y en a
pas assez alors je me suis amusé à
compter près ce cadre je me suis amusé à
compter toutes les cartes qu'ils étaient
et puis je me suis aperçu qu'en comptant
les cartes que j'avais moi j'arrivais à
décéder celle qu'avait bouille et
adversaires et ça m'a permis de vous en
prie qu'est ce que c'est qu'un bon
joueur de bridge par rapport à tout à
l'heure un bon joueur de belote enfin
j'ai un bon copain mais alors là celui
là il est aussi beaucoup mieux que moi
c'est omar sharif ah oui c'est
effectivement est-ce que vous avez des
seins en tout cas souvenir un bon
souvenir d'une partie de bridge à nous
raconter aujourd'hui non j'ai pas
tellement de souvenirs d'abord sa
passion mauvais vous perdez généralement
non c'est pas ça ça passerait pas à
l'antenne ah bon
millions le brésil c'est épouvantable
parce que les ménages un ménage qui joue
au bridge les styles tous les soirs
c'est un code d'immenses le mari en
gueule sa femme la femme de son mari on
peut peut-être penser que c'est à tous
les jeux qui vaut mieux peut-être
choisir comme partenaire quand on veut
jouer un jeu de société quel cas il vaut
mieux se séparer de tout les sépare est
chargé d'une régie me direz si j'ai
raison madame à nice mais on dit le
bridge est un petit peu snob la réalité
quelque chose de beaucoup plus
populaires joué par plus de gens non non
non nous occuper de cet avis était que
ça dans le temps il ya a changé en
maintenant c'est fini il ya des
étudiants mon dieu qu'est-ce qu'il en
vaut que si l'on remonte trop vieux
joueur comme moi sont bien meilleurs qui
jouent d'une façon de merveilleuses
[Musique]